welcome back to uh what's true news
everyone's losing but some people are
winning but most people are losing i
think we're all losers here
[Music]
welcome losers yeah good to see you yeah
you're a loser
i'm not sure on you yet i think i'm a
loser is there another stop what you're
doing
raid shadow legend sponsored this show
bam ray shadow legends
bam you guys been in the dungeons you've
been getting on with the golems
dungeons what no we can't say that now
you can find millions of real people
in a real online battle where can you do
that russ up
raid shadow legends my favorite video
game of all time not only did they
sponsor the show and have sponsored the
show for a very long time now which
we're very grateful for it means a lot
they're also making it easy to endorse
you know why it's actually a pretty good
game they've got the arena function
millions of people on there playing
against each other you know you could
take on people i could take on people i
took them all on me right sure no i get
that do you see
fear in these eyes a little but not a
lot what about now a little less a
little less
explore millions of champion
combinations and master countless
tactics as you can take on
raid bosses dungeon runs campaign
battles and with hundreds of artifacts
to equip and over 500 champions
blessed with unique skills just like you
you're blessed with the unity
yeah work rest and invest you can build
your team develop your champion
and raid your way okay now to set myself
a little challenge i've started with the
new champion just here
yeoman level one all right so i'm
getting into it and this is probably
what you'll see when you first download
the game look at him his little archer
how good are those graphics
second that is actually really good how
do they do that on the mobile
i actually don't know how they do it
because look when you can zoom like
right in on people look at his little
face
he looks amazing and he's got his little
bow and stuff brian let me give you a
little tip the fastest way to level up
your champion is through the farming
campaign
oh yeah i think yeah everyone knows you
can grind that xp
and get loads of silver and i know how
much you love silver
i like grinding this month on raid it's
absolutely jam-packed there's loads of
new content coming out including a load
of new champions
brand new champions on the game every
month we go could they add any more
champions
it genuinely is ridiculous so i'm
definitely going to be trying to summon
as many of those new champions as
possible to help me along
the way what you got your champions are
[__] yeah i don't know if we can that's
actually that's actually a lie because
they don't make by champions that's
that's a good point yeah so if you guys
want to get a huge head start in raid
and you haven't already downloaded it
which would be crazy on your behalf
either hit the link in the description
or
scan this qr code new players will get
this epic
hero chenoru i know for a fact that
you're in
feisty not only that but you get 200k
silver one xp boost
one energy refill and one ancient shard
so you can summon an awesome champion as
soon as you get into the game and you'll
find your extra awards
here in your inbox just up there see so
go take a look at that as well worth a
look thanks a lot for raid shadow
legends for sponsoring this show
it's as easy as that click the link or
scan the qr code we'll see you guys on
the game
[Music]
[Applause]
when will these youtubers stop fighting
hopefully never
because then we'd have no content no
we'd be just fine we just
keep making better content than we
already make and we wouldn't be talking
about people who
know how to fight nobody watches the
meaningful stuff the
views speak for themselves right then
let's get back to
millionaires hitting each other that's
what they should rebrand it that social
clubs
social gloves otherwise we call them
condoms maybe austin
broome should have thought about that so
that he wouldn't have so many children
to be fair they make a cute couple so i
imagine that you know those two
just they love to [__] yeah yeah they're
just boning around
all the day every day when he's not
jabbing your face he's
jabbing something else he's tongue
punching the fart box
too far definitely too far so um
austin mcbroom fresh off the back of his
win against
bryce hall which pretty much everyone
who's seen five seconds of bryce hall
boxing
knew was coming yeah now once a pop of
the chump
daddy wants a bentley as he calls this
fight let's have a quick look at
austin's
skills you want to see austin's skills
okay it's all about experience the more
sparring the better
i don't know what that was no yeah that
was just a little oh dig and then they
have a little hug
and then they're away genuinely you've
got to be careful around austin man is
fertile
he's like compost bryce hall's been in
over 40 straight fights oh
very interesting i've worked something
out if you master just the basics of
boxing you can win in a youtube fight
so most people skip straight to their
complex stuff yeah they go how do i
knock someone out and their trainers go
well we need to work out their mego
[__] it how do i knock someone out
you've got to land a punch first yeah
that's the key here yeah that's
bryce he missed lesson one anderson two
three four and five
bryce is such an [__] right that i
like him he's good at
the the [__] talking he's right he makes
the show
like i appreciate someone who stares it
up a bit it's the fighting he can't do
i don't know how allowed him to go into
this fight knowing so
little like in three months which is
roughly what he had
you can learn so much you can really
nail the basics
he didn't even know how a job jabbing
you should have
you know to a decent standard within a
week what were they doing honestly like
bro
you earned millions off of this you need
to find yourself a good training income
if you're ever going to do this again
because that lovely little
nice wallpapery place where you've been
boxing it it isn't working for you
it obviously didn't work for your man
[__] um taylor it didn't work for him
either right you both took old
you're athletic your young guys get a
proper
come just get yourself a proper gym try
and find a place with no wallpaper do
you think wallpaper
if there's wallpaper in a boxing gym go
to another one big tip is if they've
interior decorated
in a nice way not a good gym your job's
probably gonna end up [__]
gyms need to look like shitholes yeah
like they they need to be bits falling
apart the roof needs to be leaking
people need to be coming in you need to
be able to smell the toilets at least
from about 10 feet away
that's when you know you've joined fight
club uh also when you get in the ring
lift the old hands up i want to be able
to see the face on tick tock but in the
ring
as little of that just genuinely like
laurence mckenna
is telling you what you [__] up on in
boxing you've badly [__] up when i can
turn around and go
lift the hands mate you know when your
trainers went give us that killer look
you didn't go
baby yeah
i'll get in the [__] corner let's go
let's keep it clean and get in the
[__] corners
he's supposed to swear the referee
showed more aggression than bryce hall
did these two are just standing there
big right here he's picking up he wants
the million bucks
even just this a pause on this the way
austin
is posturing versus bryce bryce is just
a sitting [__] dog what did they
teach you my guy
bryce mcduck
[Applause]
austin mcbroom butter the living [__]
out of uh bryce hall
and now he he's wanting to fight ksi
i love that do you know what this is
like for me it's like
when you win like a local karaoke
contest in a pub
and then you're like now i'm ready for x
factor right yes because
everyone else in the pub who are your
friends and barely listen
to any other music go you you should
sing you should sing
honestly bro that was sick the way that
you just did that and you go
maybe i should really maybe based on
what i've seen
i don't think this is a great fight for
austin miproo you know he's beaten
that little bryce hall kid up and now
the step up is going to be gigantic
all of a sudden the punchers coming back
to you are going to hurt
he won against a punch bag the other
night this is not the same thing
but it will be [__] entertaining yeah
you know and they've both got huge
audiences and there's a shitload of
money to be made there so
i'm kind of excited for it and both very
fertile men
i imagine jj's been out watching logan
and jake
and and and gabe like a lot of the lads
having
a great time putting on a great show and
he's probably missing that because he
was the guy
you know but in in the meantime they've
sort of took over um so now this
is a great way for him to get back in
knock the cobwebs off
train hard and get ready for the mega
fight
yeah the one we all want the fight the
the biggest fight of
all youtube time but literally there is
no bigger fight out there yeah jake paul
ksi
bad blood that's what they should call
it bad blood
why they have some sort of condition
also deji had a fight that night what
you didn't tell me that top shock story
today deji
lost a boxing match that's right one of
the best boxers in the game is
finally set to retire after losing his
how many boxing matches he had because
he was prolific in his career
sorry though he also claimed all the
wins that jake paul had though didn't he
because he just about
got past it was he didn't do that to me
wasn't it how do we treat deji now do we
feel sorry for deji
he got paid a lot of money did he to get
in the ring how much money are we
talking here what's give me a ballpark
figure
three other guys on the card that i know
of got paid five million dollars five
million dollars so
the fact that deji is arguably as big of
an influencer as those three guys
it's likely he got at least a million if
not multiple
how many pairs of comedy shorts do you
think he's going to be able to buy this
is incredible a lifetime a lifetime
supply of comments very much the willy
wonka
very much so yeah did you look like he
was wearing a wedding dress that looks
more like a
sanitary towel with a hole cut in it
it's just not a good it's not a good cut
it's a wedding dress but i get you the
cut is bad and that's the thing and i do
get the feeling that his team genuinely
went to the local store and went is
there a rug here can we
yep there we go snip snip snip deji do
you remember
mike tyson he goes no and they go he was
a really good fighter okay
put this on you're just like him
the music actually sounds like it's from
like a satanic wedding
tonight you will be marrying vinnie
hacker
he will take your soul he looks so
serious
this is the thing right if i was going
into a fight where i knew i hadn't
trained enough and that i had it at best
four minutes of energy in me i would not
look that confident
or it's that we misread his face at the
time you know when you think someone's
smiling at you and ultimately they're
just sort of
squeezing out a fart i think that's
similar to what deji's done here we
thought deji looked confident
but ultimately it was him going i'm
absolutely
[__]
[Music]
this is the most [__] mind-boggling
entrance i've ever seen it's amazing
though isn't it like part of me
absolutely loves it
yeah deji credit to you you made an
incredible entrance i index it
i'm worried yeah it was the middle bit
that was the issue
deji a question was it the weight of the
poncho on the
ring walk that you think tired you out
it's a deontay one
i think yeah he is a man of many
interests
i remember laughing at that on the night
and being like you know when there's a
funeral which is basically what this was
that omego she was a woman of many
interests uh
gardening uh she she did love her dogs
oh she loved golf
she did love golf towards the end of her
life though towards the end of her life
i really hope deji
puts that in his twitter bio a mind of
what i will say i thought fousey and
keemstar were great and i wish everyone
on there more
yeah this old wrestling guy who has
nothing to do with youtube and no
[__] clue about any of these guys
what the hell were you thinking yeah and
having
the coach the wrestling guy like
literally no [__] clue at all
must have been a friend of a friend or
something like that he created a graphic
novel
in the forbidden city sorry deji created
a graphic
novel what half of the [__] i didn't
even know
deji graphic novel it is called kung fu
i'm buying a copy right now deji this
isn't a graphic
novel this is a [__] like he's
downloaded a package and then slightly
adapted it
i mean what that's not aggressive this
is just some
pictures hey guys it's comedyshortsgamer
here
oh man are we all about to have some
serious fun
no doubt many of you have been following
my videos on youtube probably
exclusively and you'll know that i love
prank videos kung fu and chinese
food was he training for kung fu and
then they got it that's where the
mistakes
put the gloves on you don't need to go
longer than four minutes because one
strike they're out they're dead
yeah exactly yeah you should have done
the kung fu stuff they started putting
the gloves on me
what are you doing i've been training
for kung fu i'm i'm used to
bare hand combat what what's going on
here hand to hand strip to the waist a
fight to the death
the only way to truly understand what a
work of art this is because we haven't
got time
to read the whole thing let's check the
amazon reviews up someone put here one
time extremely disappointed i bought
this new comic book expecting to be
expecting it to look
new and fresh for a gift however it's
all battered in each corner
just like daddy i suppose that's
literally what it says
as well though and that was in 2010
put there for us to make that joke not
for the young reader but for my 12 year
old son
should come with age restrictions due to
some of the wording you
had to take the book away wow i'd take
the book away so not happy boy
on christmas eve why'd you give him a
[__] book i know we're having a bit
of a laugh
but it was a really entertaining fight
deji went for it yeah the worst thing
i can watch is someone just play it safe
he absolutely tried to take vinnie
hatta's head off but that's because
maybe if he'd paced himself a bit
he wouldn't have gussed out all right so
deji is basically throwing everything
but the kitchen sink at this kid he's
dropping his hands down he's not
protecting himself and he's thinking
i'm gonna hit him a few times i'm gonna
put him away and i'll be on my way the
problem is
deji just didn't hit hard enough to hurt
this kid sure and this kid had clearly
trained
to go the five rounds and was fit enough
so at the end of round two they have a
minute rest they come on for round three
and we see one of the
only things we've not seen in youtube
boxing a
serious punch being thrown no no he
takes a knee because um he's just
exhausted right okay after having a
minutes rest you're right
all right here we go round number three
hacker and the easy joke here is uh
black lives matter but the
complex joke is that he was actually
going to propose to him he is pretty
we've seen one proposal is it time for
the first
gay proposal in youtube boxing i'm all
for it
big shots big shot from jenny hacker wow
[__] teddy's little face deji looks
like he's just been animated by pixar
genu
like this is one of those situations
where when you think something's gonna
go your way
and all of a sudden it's a lot harder
than you ever thought possible
that's a look of like what is happening
anyone getting their ass kicked
you gotta have a little sympathy for
them even if
he didn't train hard and he brought it
all on himself still a little bit of
empathy that is kind of what i keep
thinking here is if i'd have been in
that position
what would i have wanted people around
me to react like how would i have wanted
you to
treat he's paid the price the ass
kicking is the price you know i mean the
one thing i would say is
the thing that adds a little salt on the
wound you know previously he'd lost to
jake paul so
every time jake paul won he could be
like well you know i did all right
against them he
went instantly and often whenever jake
paul was doing anything he'd sort of
attach his name and go
you know i want the rematch but right
but now this skinny little 18 year old
who has
very little following by comparison who
quote
only did this for the money yeah out
trained you
and beat the hell out of him like that's
the worst bit about it i think is
the other kids gained from this steady
has lost massively here oh
my my stamina failed me again my stamina
failed me
i do like the way he attaches sort of a
separate identity to stamina
as if it isn't actually him failing
himself he literally went home and he
was stubborn he didn't turn up against
i like the idea it's like you know venom
in that film and he
like comes out and goes sorry deji i
didn't mean to let you down he's like
stamina
i guess you i will see you guys soon
that's the kung fu yeah exactly
and don't worry about me i am all good
as you can see i'm more cheerful
i'm happy they're saying this isn't a
facade i know when someone goes
nah nah everything's absolutely fine
it's it's great i'm not pretending at
all
i didn't think you were pretending no no
no one around here is pretending or
putting on a facade certainly not me
you're like uh yeah okay i'm i'm living
life all right and i needed this
this is uh somewhat humbled me it's not
humbled them it's somewhat humbled
this i believe is i guess in some ways
in a tiny small way sort of you know in
a roundabout way where i didn't really
put in any effort and nothing really
happened
it's humbled me i'm humbled by this guys
i knew some people were going to tell me
to give up
pack it in but i have no quit in me
that's just me the best thing is
when he was eating in the evening they
went daddy you should stop eating you
went i haven't acquitted me
all the people at the event all the
people on the internet you guys are
lovely honestly
and the ones also calling me a fat [__]
i i appreciate it
you're welcome you're very welcome i
credit him for that because he's taken
this like a man he's not interview
mother
uh yeah you gotta you gotta enjoy that
and just go yeah [__] it
ksi made a video about it i think maybe
first we should watch
his girlfriends behind the scenes before
the fight okay
bring it bring it up so first day
and this toilet sucks what the [__] he
drinking he blocked the toilet he
literally blocked the toilet no no
wonder what was he eating
on the run up to this yeah i just did a
regular [__]
and it blocked the toilet it's brown
that's his girlfriend
laughing if i had a ship that blocked
the toilet the first thing i do is not
go to flu and go come look at this
let's be honest though to be honest in
the toilet with a huge [__]
to be with deji you got to be a chilled
out kind of girl you know
i respect that she's got a sense of
humor good for her i love the idea it
cuts back to him and he's still got his
pants around his ankle
toilet roll's still hanging out with his
arms oh the toilet i kept flashing it
you know
you know me i've got that got no queen
i've got no quitting me we've broken
lawrence ladies and gentlemen
we've got to stop true that [__] just
would not flush but you know me
got no quitting me honest it clogged the
[__] toilet
look his actual trousers are still town
i didn't know
i made a joke thinking it was ridiculous
that his trousers might still be down
they are down i don't understand well
how do they not have a [__] power
flush
[Laughter]
trainer i'm gonna go to miami and smash
him up i'm done i'm the guy that's been
beating dead yet for the past two months
[__] out cause he just plucked some
random uh you know cab drivers and said
fancy a job
i am rob i'm 32 years old
i am crazy
what the [__] is rob doing matt i have
no idea rob is this rob's on a stag dude
yeah and they've just colored him and
said you're coming with us he's like
what's happening he's like we're
fighting in miami
bring walk i'm off for it james score
unbelievable he thinks he's on the call
it's the serious way with which she
approached the fight that i think most
people respected they told you to
disrespect me
in what way disrespect which part
offended you you said
genuinely they went back and forth on
the press conference now
this fight makes more sense than ever
they both lost their last fight they
both struggled with cardio they're both
about the same size
they're both big names it would be
[__] great
oh [__] that's what's up
this guy is such a character though he's
weirdly stealing the show of this whole
thing
comedy gold i don't know who the [__] is
but he's hilarious i don't know what
he's doing
the fact that he is involved in a fight
camp in some way is incredible
he's there just to keep the level he
just he just raises the spirit exactly
i bet you after dead you got chilled he
was like come on come on boys let's go
for drinks
literally we're like 20 minutes away
from the [__] fight and this guy's
doing pole dancing behind deji in a room
this explains a lot
what you need is a team that's about you
this is kind of what we're witnessing
though that deji is a very playful guy
and he's surrounded by people who are
also very playful and trying to play up
to that nature whereas he needs someone
who's a little bit
well a lot more strict regimented but
vidal tried to do that and he quit
sorry he's got no queen yeah no quit
that's just me deji's big brother
you all know him ksi so i had enough of
this [__] and i wanted to give him some
home truths
as only your own brother can i am
disappointed
in your team and the people around you
man how and why they thought it would be
a good idea for you to enter the ring
looking like that is beyond me man it
was it was embarrassing
have they no shame or are they there
just to massage your ego
while you're still paying them and
giving them clowns should we just cut
back to
the guy doing the
i am crazy yeah
exactly you said that you gassed out in
the jake fight that's why you lost
so we accepted that and we said cool in
your next fight
hopefully you gassing out shouldn't be a
problem
at all with the fight against vinnie
hacker they niced you
they gave you two minute rounds and it
was only five rounds
and somehow you gassed out quicker it
just makes that it is very easy
to get fit enough to do that you've
officially become an easy stepping stone
people would happily fight you now your
big credible name to
boost an opponent's career and you're an
easy fight i think jj has got it spot on
and he just needs to start looking after
himself a bit better because for years
he's been able to pin it on the jake
paul thing and oh
you know i was good i was good i was
good now you can't light yourself
anymore
and there is natural talent there and it
would be a shame if he just squandered
it
we wish him well on the comeback i
always like deji i i think both of us
hope that he does have a comeback and
that things are good for him
genuinely i know we make some jokes but
good luck to him i hope we see him back
better than ever
some opponents foosie yep i mean
genuinely
i think a lot of people tune in to see
fousey versus deji but the one person
who did kind of steal the show
big gibber yeah big kid absolutely i
mean i can't wait when this is done to
look at the scorecard and see how many
landed oh big left hand for kim straight
oh
big right right gibb looked in
incredible shape
gibb's always been fit but he's never
looked like shredded but this time he
turned up looking like he was ready for
baywatch
and mentally he looked in the zone when
he did the face off
like he's been there before a few times
now and he knows what it's like to lose
the fiat was gone from him and he he
just looked like he was ready to put on
an absolute masterpiece
there was this air of confidence that i
don't think any other fighter on that
card had
i think he beats everyone that night the
way he mixed his shots up the way he
defended himself the way he fought
you can say the work that he'd put in
was
way more than anyone else there and that
is you know the difference like
deji and gibb could not be more polar
opposite and in tallant
you could probably make the case where
at the start maybe deji
when he first thought jake was above the
level of gabe in terms of natural
ability but
what gabe has done is worked and worked
and worked
and never stopped and now he's getting
the rewards the combined scores put the
bout
in favor of a majority draw
what what the entire
uk youtube fanbase went crazy us
included we were watching live
47 total punches landed 21
from big giver it is a joke by the way
this is a [__] disgrace
did tweet as well did not i never tweet
anymore no you never tweet but
ultimately this got you out but when i
do
wow you get the rituals yeah i'm angry
so basically everyone who was watching
tweeted what a load of [__] this is
yeah and then magically
one of the most corrupt boxing decisions
ever
is overturned once keemstar starts doing
some digging
yeah he starts prying around and all of
a sudden they're like
oh no um we can overturn this decision
because keemstar put a treat out you
will never work with influencers again
when i find out who you are
and boom we got the real decision coming
out well done keemstar but more
importantly well done gabe
he did get the win and they overturned
that [__] draw
so ultimately now we see why deju is
fighting this came from the iska the
international sport karate association
i'd imagine they sometimes cover kung fu
as well two liam and social gloves after
reviewing the result of holder for
holder versus gib fight
eson gibb won by a unanimous
decision we don't have to read the rest
of it yeah the the interesting thing is
they were like
two social clubs so yeah yeah put put to
social clubs on the start the email so
that they don't think we were involved
in any of them yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know if social groups were
behind it but the fact that they tweeted
out
that gibb had lost right as the decision
had not been read yet
right as it was about to it was that's
just strange the whole thing
stunk the worst thing about it is brian
that they're right in this letter
it did take a moment away from gibb he
deserved his moment in the spotlight in
the ring on that night when he could
have gone
yes i once that's why they need to make
the main event yeah next time
elsewhere in the youtube world trisha
paytas for once took all of her makeup
off to give us a message
i had this um feeling in my heart that i
need to step away from frenemies and
it's
really really with a heavy heart that i
say that the five percent thing
and ethan getting like 100 of the
highlights like that's not an issue
that's
the money is not the issue for me as
like half the views like i
i do feel like i contributed half to
frenemies building the hr channel like i
would have loved to have frenemies on my
channel and like build up my channel
i could have produced i could have built
that's like i'm capable of this stuff
you know
i see why she wants some of the cash
although she's saying it's not about
cash it's not about cash yeah
if you look at ethan like to be fair he
has a track record of being very
consistent
building sets building studios producing
content getting it out reliably
religiously this girl
isn't is not that i don't know if you've
subscribed to her only fans she's
religiously getting that [__] out
in my experience from what i understand
he basically did a lot and she turned up
and i'm not saying she didn't contribute
in a way
but for her to say half and half is is
nonsense to me
in terms of investment he had a
successful podcast audience already
yeah so then transferring that audience
into another podcast with somebody else
was it quite an easy thing for him to do
for her to start off a podcast from
scratch on her channel it would never
have had
the same pull etc here's trisha with a
semi-faded receipt about the guys on set
wanting to have sex with her i'm like
the first episodes of me being on h3
like the guys
reading how i look and if they would
date me or have sex with me or something
from the very beginning of everyone who
she
does anything with she accuses them of
this sort of [__]
sooner or later and unfortunately she
may be telling the truth
but when you're pointing the finger at
anyone you encounter
along your youtube journey at some point
people have got to go
there i can't really believe that
because it's just like everyone
according to youth people who are always
the victim
i just avoid them because i'm not saying
people can't be the victim in life but
when you're consistently making yourself
out to be that person
it can't be everyone else all the time
and with her it always is
now there's a spectrum of victimhood
where some people are
very much a victim then there are other
people who can sometimes cast themselves
in the role of victim
and very much sort of take that up as a
result i'm not saying that she's never
been
legitimately the victim yeah i'm sure
she has but unfortunately
she's muddied the water so much with all
her [__] accusations over the years
that it gets to a point where i don't
know what's what so i just avoid it yeah
so it's hard to know
what's real and what is because she is a
[__] right yeah we know that yeah
like
if you look on her channel the amount of
videos she's released where it's like
i'm suffering from this i've got that i
i'm like she might as well say i'm dying
in a week like you know it's that
flippant with how ridiculous it is and
there's something quite tragic about
watching trisha which i think
we don't watch her religiously sometimes
we have to cover on true news and i've
got to admit every time i'm coming left
with a very sad feeling
this is a person who has serious issues
that need addressing and whilst it might
be sometimes fun
and sometimes a little bit voyeuristic
to look in on her life and be like oh
[__]
really [__] for you at least i'm all
right after a while
these people just need help it just gets
sad yeah yeah when you look at her you
just think i mean you found a way to
monetize your misery
but surely there comes a point where you
need to sort that out i'm not playing
the victim
i'm just i don't when you say i'm not
playing the victim i
just you better have an answer
immediately and the reality is
she knows she's playing the victim which
is why she runs out of words there
she's [__] caught in her own life i'm
not even angry at her for talking [__]
like
it's just what she does but if you watch
it and take her seriously
you probably need to sort of reevaluate
what you're what you're watching on your
youtubes at what point does the internet
just say we're going to put trisha down
and i don't mean that like a dog i mean
more sort of we're going to leave you
there trisha right okay you need to sort
yourself out
come back when you're in a better place
and will welcome you with open arms uh
anyway ethan responded
nearly four million views should we have
a little shot you
we started dressing up and then you quit
the show or whatever yeah i'll be the
mask and you can be cameron diaz
yeah yeah you would look hot as cameron
diaz actually i've got the cheekbones
and the lips yeah check i've got
cheekbones on lips yes
in that you have a face she can say
whatever she wants
you know what she puts out publicly and
then you know if i just sit and take it
everything's distorted and if i say
anything then i'm the bad guy
for you know coming after something
which is not my intention
because she's a woman there's an
immediate dynamic there before they even
exchange words and as a man
he has to play this a lot more carefully
than she can sling as much
[__] his way and if it sticks so what
but the minute he sort of
replies he's the bad guy he's right the
problem with this is
you knew what you signed up for the
minute you get into business
with trisha you know this shitstorm is
on the way that train
is never late with trisha paytas so i
kind of think you know you did a deal
with the devil
and and they you know this was
inevitable lived by the sword die by
this
yeah yeah you know he probably weighed
up and thought it'll probably be a good
ride
and i i don't mean that in the you know
and eventually when it blows up we'll
get a load of views
it'll keep things interesting he's like
the hawk he sees this a mile away
from one of your favorite chubby
funsters to the nation's chubby funster
boris johnson is back
well he survived every storm possible
and now we've all made it through that's
right barely anyone died from covid and
on the other side
we're seeing how well he dealt with it
so these are allegedly
messages on whatsapp between boris
johnson and dominic cummings
agree about valance and witty on ppe
it's a disaster it was yeah i can't
think finally some honesty
he literally says this i can't think of
anything except taking hancock off
and putting gove on now some people
might remember that months ago i called
this they basically do
a [__] merry-go-round of these stupid
pricks that they trot out one after the
other and go
send them to the wolves this week that
literally is what they're proposing
the queen's been doing it for most of my
life so this is uh dominic cummings
this is coming and he says with the cub
off such a total [__] show i'm afraid
this would have been a severe risk of
making it worse
not better okay to which boris johnson
replies
okay wtf do we do
another meeting with matt and stevens
and dated and go
blah blah blah that's great leadership
yeah great leadership
i don't think i've ever seen a good
leader ever ever put the phrase wtf do
we do
midway through a [__] whatsapp group
when you're the prime minister of
[__] england
you think you're [__] winston
churchill you think churchill's up at 10
p.m
texting some [__] trollop on
hancock's performance
uh after getting the run down from
where the stats are going yeah he
replies totally [__] hopeless
right okay to which i believe he's
talking about matt hancock by the way a
guy who
literally on his gravestone should have
the words totally [__] hopeless i do
like that yeah it's the one thing i've
agreed with boris on since it's all
[__] restarted the good news is is
that the corvaid
numbers right now are at a record low in
terms of
deaths in the uk basically this is the
best it's ever been
since the first uh outbreak but we've
extended the lockdown the restrictions
are still going to be in place for
another month just in case and here's
the thing right i think everyone had
sort of gotten to grips with the idea
that there would be restrictions at some
point but it's the endlessness of those
restrictions that i think people are now
feeling
i feel like i'm living in the
never-ending story i'm just waiting for
that big talking [__] dog
it's just the fact that no one knows
when it's going to end it keeps getting
extended we
we're kept in the dark back that's
what's pissing me off also
the problem is that the data as uh boris
calls it
that we use to prolong the restrictions
was
out of date so the data is out of date
boris as you'd say and this is very much
language you would understand
wtf curvy modelling that pushed back
june 21
to 21st was based on out-of-date data
didn't check the date on it didn't you
know yeah should have checked the date
should we
overturn it and give people the complete
freedom back as promised
nah best to be safe than sorry but the
date i was out of date so you're not
never mind i've said it now
i can't undo what i've said no but you
you are undoing what you said because
you promised us all
that we'd be freeing out of this
bollocks by now ultimately i'm a prime
minister that works on how people see me
not actual practicality well as long as
people love me
that's good the sad thing is is i'm
actually in agreeance with a former
prime minister
about this we will not eradicate covet
19 from the uk
there will not be a time when we can say
that there will never be another case of
kovit 19
in this country secondly variants will
keep on coming
if the government's position is that we
cannot open up
travel until there are no new variants
elsewhere in the world
then we will never be able to travel
abroad ever again
and the third fact that the government
needs to state much more clearly is that
sadly people will die from covert here
in the uk
in the future as 10 to 20 000 people do
every year from flu a little bit of a
news flash there from uh
teresa people will die of kovade
in the future it's about time we got my
heads around that this notion that
anything and everything
must be done to prevent that no matter
what the ramifications are on the other
end no matter the
thousands of cancer appointments that
have been delayed and will then result
in deaths what impact it has on the
children of today no matter what impact
it has on the businesses of today no
matter how many people die on the other
end or
or end up in the [__] on the other end
we've got a justifier because people
might die of covid and the fact that
we've got the vast majority of the
population still
vaccinated when we were promised 15
million vaccines and then
we're able to have freedom that lie was
swept under the [__] carpet super
quick that the nhs
is there to support this country this
country
should not be changing its behavior for
the foreseeable future
because we have built an nhs that isn't
strong enough to withstand what we've
been going through
we should then focus on helping the nhs
improving the nhs
actually spending money on the nhs the
answer isn't tell everyone to [__]
stay indoors
forever we've done everything that
they've they've told us to do we've all
played by the rules for as long as
humanly possible
enough's enough isn't it am i the only
one who feels this way because it's been
tweeted out a lot this and i'm gonna
reply three weeks to flatten the curve
12 weeks to turn the tide
back to normal by october we can save
christmas freedom by easter
june 21st one last push for summer how
many times are we gonna have this
thing pulled a bit further away and part
of it is because the minute they
actually
stop this from officially being a
pandemic
a lot of the powers that has enabled
them to pad the pockets
of their [__] friends with all these
[__] contracts that they've been
handing out go away
the cynic in me feels like because the
the kovid deaths are so
low i can only imagine that what they're
trying to do before
the end is [__] fill the [__]
briefcase a while they can't there's
still people who've had both vaccines
they're they're [__] wearing masks
outside non-stop they're [__]
terrified
the risk now is so [__] low and yet
they're not acknowledging it they don't
want us to realize
actually the things that are completely
different i'm just frustrated because
we should have options in government we
should have
someone else another party we could turn
to and go this lot of [__]
will you sort it out right now i'm at a
point where i'd vote for anyone who said
i'll just end the lockdown immediately
you got my vote what do you want to do
do you want to set us all on fire
afterwards i don't even mind just give
us you know what i mean like
i'm sorry i'm so desperate right for
any anything to challenge this because
labour are pathetic
i'm desperate for a media to actually
question
instead of just spreading the fear and
actually look into
these [__] and actually hold them up
for what they've been doing wrong
instead of just
you know acting as a propaganda machine
we've got nothing
the internet idiots like me and him
we're having to come up and say this
because i'm
i'm just [__] off can i now show you
richard maidly this man used to be
just the biggest face in english
television so he's taken over from
uh fat boy here's richard madeley and
the woman
on twitter he says look at the age she
left making a mistake is getting a
tattoo that you regret or a one-night
stand but deliberately joining a
terrorist organization
uh just to put this into context he's
talking about shame shamima begum you
know the woman who went to
isis the isis yeah and i love how we say
that as if she just
nipped to sort of portugal for a holiday
kind of what happened just popped off
the isis in many ways for her that kind
of what
was actually shocked uh and then richard
comes out with what i can only describe
as a very profound thought there's one
interesting point i was thinking about
this last night
obviously we have the nuremberg trials
after the war and we hanged quite quite
a few nasties and imprisoned
a lot of others and we let them out
eventually but we didn't go after the
hitler youth
i love him he's the most portrait [__]
ever
so good though so that was true news
enjoyed the truth of it all yep and i
hope you enjoyed some of the falsity of
it all
do be sure to subscribe to the true
jordan youtube channel check this out on
twitch we're
live streaming all your favorite
sporting events all the time apparently
on uh
tick tock as well with the kickoff and
you're on in are you do instagram don't
well we're all on we're on
everything yeah check us out be nice to
each other and stop
giving yourself such a hard time in your
life yeah no yeah not to each other to
yourself
cut yourself some [__] exactly be a
better friend to you
exactly you don't need your friends you
just need yourself and that's all you
you know in here they love you yeah we
love you we love you don't
forget and keep buying all the stuff
that we don't yeah we don't finish on
the love leave them with the love
love look down the lines and say i love
you i love you
right now say it with conviction i love
you excellent there we go see you next
time